willkommen im boateng einem kleinen dorf
in über 2000 metern höhe unweit der
armenischen grenze
hier ticken die uhren ein wenig anders
als im rest der türkei denn hier haben
die frauen das sagen ob draußen auf dem
feld oder im stall
dahinter steht eine lange geschichte die
mit schweizer käse begann hüllt die
vorsitzende der landwirtschaftlichen
kooperative von boateng erzählt
besuchern im museum des dorfes gern von
dem deutschen alexander kaiser dem mann
der vor mehr als 100 jahren erkannte
dass auf diesem hochplateau mit seinen
saftigen wiesen ideale bedingungen für
die herstellung des berühmten
emmentalers bestehen
dieses dorf hat alexander kaiser viel zu
verdanken
auch seiner tochter die das erbe ihres
vaters fleißig weiter geführt sie haben
uns viele käse rezepturen hinterlassen
die auch ich erst lernen musste und die
anderen frauen der kooperative stellen
hier nicht irgendeinen käse her
ihre spezialität ist der türkische cars
kwk wie er klingt nicht von ungefähr
nach der schweizer käsesorte grün wie es
dazu kam das weiße band coaching urenkel
des deutschen pioniers und heute einer
der wenigen männer die in bor teppe
etwas zu sagen haben
mein urgroßvater kam mit dem schweizer
freund auf seiner reise aus dem kaukasus
hierher nach den wirren der russischen
oktoberrevolution
sie ließen eine käserei nach schweizer
vorbild errichten
auch das gebäude hat er selbst entworfen
[Musik]
hier wurde dann zum ersten mal der ksk
via käse hergestellt
doch später verfiel die käserei das erbe
geriet in vergessenheit
viele männer des dorfes zogen in den
sechziger und siebziger jahren des
vergangenen jahrhunderts auf der suche
nach arbeit weg aber die frauen besannen
sich auf das erbe der beiden käse
pioniere symbolisch baute die alte
käserei wieder mit auf und ihr mann
unterstützte sie ganz selbstverständlich
lieblingen sagte er
wenn du dir diese aufgabe zutraut und an
dich glaubst dann glaube ich auch an
dich dann stehe ich hinter dir
heute ist die 46-jährige so etwas wie
die käse botschafterin des ortes ihr
mann geht ihr zur hand eine
ungewöhnliche konstellation muss er
zugeben
unsere gesellschaft ist ja schon recht
patriarchalisch geprägt die männer
bestimmt aber hier haben die frauen
meiner meinung nach den platz bekommen
die frauen von borat apple haben ihren
graviert zu einem verkaufsschlager
gemacht als gäbe es keine türkische
wirtschaftskrise nicht nur ein dorfladen
drängen sich die besucher der käse wird
im ganzen land verkauft und neuerdings
sogar bis nach hongkong exportiert und
die 12.000 besucher hatten wir allein im
vergangenen jahr
das freut uns denn es hilft der
entwicklung unseres dorfes und es bringt
die frauen hier voran
das beispiel sollte schule machen auf
dem land in der türkei
denn die provinz ist immer noch
abgehängt aber das können wir sehen
frauen mit kreativen ideen ändern
dann bringt sie die besuchergruppe noch
zum bus um gleich danach wieder die kühe
hinaus auf die weiden zu treiben die
frauen von boateng so scheint es haben
nicht nur das sagen sondern auch die
ganze arbeit